[Musique]
pendant ce temps en indre-et-loire
pauline la youtube aux pâtissières
débarquant terrain boueux première étape
devant nîmes version dans le monde du
végétarisme je vais à la rencontre de
elsa qui est cuisinière elle m'a donné
rendez vous chez ca maraîchères alors ça
se voit je pense que je me trompe pas
d'endroit des légumes partout l'état de
mes chaussures et pour tout comprendre
du végétarisme pauline pourra compter
sur elza cuisinière et traiteur
estampillé végétariens et clara une
productrice de légumes bio dont la
propriété maraîchère la petite fève
s'étend sur deux hectares
attention ces deux là sont des
passionnés merci de m'accueillir
elsa raconte nous on est où et c'est là
que je prends mes lignes jument en fait
pour ma cuisine passer à 2 km donc ce
n'est pas comme on est sur du grain à
l'onatra circuits courts c'est génial
donc on est chez toi ici en fait je
cultive ici depuis cinq ans maintenant
dès le début j'ai démarré mais culture
en bio donc avec une démarche bio il ya
eu le temps de la conversion au bout de
deux ans j'ai pu vendre mes légumes a
certifié agriculture biologique d'accord
la conversion c'est la durée minimum de
repos des sols lorsqu'il passe d'une
appellation conventionnel un traitement
biologique traduction ici pesticides y
en a pas c'est ce qu'on appelle
optimiser la terre d'accord ok je vais
vous donner encore à l'essai j'aime bien
très bien même
[Musique]
il est vrai qu'un petit rond et je suis
en train de des foires aux immenses des
salades des radis ici on produit pour
les commerces de bouche mais pas
seulement à la petite fève
on fournit aussi directement le
consommateur via les réseaux amap du
centre val de loire
le bonheur est dans le pré oui mais
aussi sous le hangar est donc soit elsa
pourquoi a fait confiance pour le choix
des légumes on a les mêmes valeurs enfin
le bio le local mais aussi la
diversification
on ne mange pas assez diversifiée dans
les assiettes donc clair elle propose
une large gamme part à la reconquête des
estomacs ans
d'ailleurs à si je peux te prendre
quelques radis natation s'est confiné
puisque ferait qu'on va travailler quand
même et je peux savoir ce qu'on va
manger c'est une surprise tu verras tout
à l'heure tu mettra la main à la pâte
une surprise multicolores à base de
radis de carottes et d'une foule de
plantes aromatiques du croquant du
gourmand on ne jouera plus que par
brigitte à risque
[Musique]